[music]
>> There are people who say no, Bukhari has
got to say for this.
Are there any say for this in Bukhari?
In this book, say Bukhari, are there any
say for this?
Who says no, raise your hand.
No say for this. Not a single in this
book I'm carrying.
Raise your hand.
1 2 3 4 5 6
Who says there are say for this, raise
your hand.
Full or down? No half.
These are the students from Jamia tul
Imam.
In this particular volume, just a couple
of minutes back I said there are no say
for this in Bukhari. Now I'm saying is
there?
It's contradictory. There are in this
book. Bukhari had a style that when he
tied the bob,
when he wrote the preface of every
collection, you know, there's a kitab of
wudu, kitab of salah, kitab of
many.
He tied a barb. Barb means he's opening
the chapter with
Barb means door, but in English, you
know, door doesn't match. When he starts
the chapter,
his main compilation is different in the
body.
But before he used the preface and used
certain hadiths which were zaif. He knew
it was zaif. For example, this hadith
was narrated by Ibn Abbas radi allahu
anhu.
He knows, for example, the people of
Medina, if it's Ibn Abbas, khalas, they
will believe in it.
But down the line, the narrators in it
may be zaif, he knows that. So, hadith
person says zaif because Ibn Abbas is
Sahaba, we agree with it. But the third,
fourth narrators are not right, may not
be thiqah, may not be truthful. So,
according to hadith is zaif, but he
mentioned that, why? Because some people
have that Ibn Abbas is there in the
chain of narrators, khalas, I'm going to
follow it. Not checking the other.
So, he purposely used certain hadiths
which were zaif.
But not in his main body.
In the book it is there, but in the
Jami'a, in the main body it's not there,
it is there only in the barb.
It's only there
in the preface.
Knowing very well it is not a sahih
hadith
because he wanted to get other people to
follow that.
So, he quotes the hadith which is not
sahih according to his criteria. It is
not even sahih according to other
people's criteria, but comes into the
preface.
If preface is the right word to use.
Do you understand? It is just to give
you
Just give me the microphone. There,
there, last, last row. You mean the the
one he uses without the sanad? Yes, only
the Barb, barb, text only barb.
In the preface, you know? That's not
part of the That's not part of the
hadith. If you see the Sahih Bukhari,
everything is a sanad. Uh the the one he
does not number. Yes, correct. The one
which will not come in 7,275. Now, here
it differs one or two here. It will not
come in 7,000 to say the
7,506
if three is not numbered. You're right.
It comes in the book but comes in
chapter. So, if you say I'm quoting say
Bukhari volume number seven book of
dress chapter number
80. So, in the chapter it starts with a
deed which is not numbered but in the
numbering everything is sahih.
So, you should have knowledge.
So, as
they
if you know these things which are very
critical
when someone may pose a question to you.
May I ask?
So, you should know it is from Bukhari
but there are scholars who have got
together and said even though the Hadith
is da'if, it becomes sahih by there is a
thing like called as chain of narrators
locking interlocking. Let's not go into
details. We can spend only years talking
only about Hadith.
This is not a session of knowledge.
But you should have certain things which
are important to know.
So, in the classification of sahih
Hadith
Bukhari had these criteria which were
additional to the five normal criteria.
But the criteria of Bukhari was the
strictest.
Imam Muslim was less strict but there
were certain criteria of Imam Muslim
which is not in Bukhari. So, according
to the Muhaddithin
the best
amongst all the sahih Hadith is the
Muttafaq Alayh.
Muttafaq Alayh
means it is appearing in Bukhari and
Muslim both.
We have the Lu'lu' wal-Marjan. There's a
compilation in English it's in two
volumes. In Arabic it's called as Lu'lu'
wal-Marjan.
And Muttafaq Alayh means it's following
the basic five criteria of sahih Hadith.
Also following criteria of Bukhari, also
Muslim.
So,
maximum tested
is the highest Muttafaq Alayh. Then
comes the Hadith which comes in Bukhari.
Sahih Bukhari.
Then which comes
third category sahih Muslim.
Fourth category of sahih Hadith is
the Muhaddithin they say that Imam
Bukhari only analyzed fixed like Hadith
and there are much more than that. So
this hadith didn't reach him. Now we are
analyzing the hadith based on the
criteria of Bukhari.
Other scholars said Imam Muslim did not
get this hadith. We are analyzing on the
criteria of Imam Muslim. The fourth
category is the hadith not compiled by
Bukhari and Muslim, but fulfill the
criteria of mutafaq alayh comes as
category four.
Category five, the hadiths is which were
not analyzed by Imam Bukhari but by
other scholars, but fulfill the criteria
of Imam Bukhari that comes as category
five. Category six is the hadith that
was not analyzed by Imam Muslim, but
analyzed by other scholars on the
criteria of Imam Muslim category six.
Then the seventh category is sahih
hadith only following the criteria of
sahih. But with a continuous chain.
Eighth category is only sahih hadith
with interlocking chain. Interlocking
chain means two hadiths are there
and there is some problem in the chain
of narration, but with interlocking with
two different hadiths, it gets
interlocked and becomes a sahih hadith.
That's category number eight. Category
number nine is a hasan hadith. Hasan
means fulfilling all the criteria.
There's a minor thing which yet it comes
into the accepted hadith. It's called as
hasan.
With a continuous chain. The 10th
category is the hadith which is hasan
but with the interlocking chain.
So in hadith of accepted hadith is again
classified into 10 categories. There are
different categories of classification.
Many. Let's not go into what's a
mutawatir hadith and what is a
This is not a session of hadith.
So in the books of hadith, the most
authentic and that should be referred is
Bukhari.
Which is nine volumes. But Imam Bukhari
only compiled that which is sahih
according to his criteria.
Now in Bukhari in 7,275
or 7,563
hadith, there are many which are common.
Common means the matter is the same,
the chain of narration is different. If
I say something, then Kamaruddin will go
and tell what Zakir Naik spoke today.
Farid may say to his friend something
else. Brother Ibrahim may say something
else. I'm saying the same thing, but it
will be who said? Brother Ibrahim's
friend told that Ibrahim said that Zakir
said.
Farid, it will be Abdul, who's a friend
of Farid, told that Farid said that
Zakir said so and so. Muhammad Muhammad,
who's a friend of Kamaruddin, told that
Kamaruddin said that Zakir said.
The matter is the same, but
chains are three different. Now, brother
Kamaruddin's friend is a good in memory,
but brother Farid's friend is weak. So,
if you hear that Abdul told that Farid
said that Zakir said so and so, Abdul is
weak. Hadith becomes
daif. Understand?
Maybe your friend is very good. I'm
going to tell Hadith becomes two.
That Ibrahim's friend told to him
that Ibrahim said that Zakir said. So,
it becomes two different Hadith, but the
matter is the same.
Correct? So, now what they've done,
they've removed the duplicate and
they've come up with a summarized
version, which has about 2,230 Hadith.
It keeps on changing, huh? So, these
numbers are approximate because in every
publisher
he has his own way of codification. So,
therefore, when we give references of
Hadith, you should also know which
publisher am I referring to.
But Darussalam is one of the most famous
publishers for English books for
authentic books.
Alhamdulillah. So, there's a summarized
version of Sahih Bukhari. Then we have
the Sahih Muslim.
Sahih Muslim, again,
it's the second most authentic
compilation.
And
this particular book in English
translation comes in four volumes.
Different publishers may have different
volumes, so please don't
get stuck to that. In Urdu, it's
different, in English different. Again,
there's a summarized version of
Sahih Muslim done by Dar-us-Salam in two
volumes.
After Sahih Muslim, there's again a
summarized version done by another group
of scholars, Dr. Muhammad Zubair and
Mrs. Dina Zubair, but the one of
Dar-us-Salam is far superior. This is
the Mukhtasar Sahih al-Bukhari. This is
Mukhtasar Sahih Muslim done by Dr.
Muhammad Zubair and Mrs. Dina Zubair.
Amongst the translations, I prefer the
one which is better by Dar-us-Salam. The
translation
nine volumes, even the summarized one.
You have the next, the third
set of books in the Kutub al-Sittah, not
Siha Sittah, Kutub al-Sittah, is Sunan
Abu Dawud.
Again, this is compiled by Imam Hafiz
Abu Dawud Sulaiman bin al-Ash'ath,
that's the full name.
And again, this
also comes in five volumes. Some of the
publishers have six volumes of Abu
Dawud. Dar-us-Salam has got five volumes
of Sunan Abu Dawud. [snorts] Then you
have the Tirmidhi, Jami al-Tirmidhi. You
have Bukhari, Muslim, then Abu Dawud,
then Tirmidhi, then you have the fifth
Sunan al-Nasa'i.
The fifth in the book of
Kutub al-Sittah. Then you have Ibn
Majah.
Sunan Ibn Majah
is the sixth book in the Kutub
al-Sittah. Some scholars,
instead of Sunan Ibn Majah,
they use Imam Malik's Muwatta. That's
also very good book, authentic.
This is al-Muwatta Malik.
So, these are mainly the Kutub
al-Sittah. I've mentioned seven. If you
read these seven, you get majority of
almost most of the rulings of fiqh, etc.
So, if a student of knowledge learns
uses these six, that means he has to
have read the most important hadiths.
La
ilaha illallah.
ilaha [music] illallah.
Muhammadun
rasulullah
Muhammadun rasulullah
>> [music]
>> All you need okay yeah Allah And I need
him yeah Allah Help me out there yeah
Allah And I need him
Allah And
I need him yeah
Allah
>> [music]
>> And I need him
yeah Allah Allah Allah Allah Allah Allah
Allah
And
I need him
Allah
And I need him